Hello everybody. My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to "I Am Bread"
Now,
I took a little breather.
I meditated.
I didn't really
but I thought about peaceful thoughts
and, uh,
I just wanna get this done
now.
So that I can bury it
for the rest
of my days.
And I don't know if
I'm going to be able to do that
but,
hopefully,
everything will be fine.
Let's
do this.
Ah-
Oh
Oh-
I'm okay with this.
This seems okay.
I think I can emotionally handle this one because
this one
At least, this one,
is something not
horrifying
*hamster noise*
Bwhooah
*screams*
*sighs*
*inhales angrily*
Let's all pretend
like that didn't happen.
It was just a whisper on the wind.
Nothing happened bad
and we're all-
A-okay
Got it?
Coool
Alright, here we go.
Alright, let's take it two on this one.
Heh
Ehe
*ends in a semi-maniacal laugh* (Darki is that you?)
Nailed-
theaAhH
*unintelligible noise*
Ho
Ha
Heh heh heh heh, ha ha!
Ho ho ho ho, oh!
Ha ha!
Ah
Hee hee hee
Ah, oh fuck me
*singing* Joy inside my soul
Soul
Soul inside my heart
Heart
Heart, I'm feeling good
Good
*speaking* Noo *laughs*
Youu *laughs*
No, no, no, no, no
Not in my house!
No, no, no!
And now,
we fly!
*gerbil noise*
And now we don't die
Remember that: don't die
Ah-
Aw-
Oh
Ah
Okay
*guinea pig noise*
God, you flaps-
OhaWw
*laughs* Whoa
*angry squirrel noise* (Hey he is the king of the squirrels so this makes sense?)
Ha
This is not correct
but I am going to take it.
Oh
Ahhh! Oh!
*dying vole noise*
Okay, we're fine
Ngh
Oh, we're not fine, we're not fine, we're not fine!
Oh! Eh- Ah!
*yells*
*yells louder*
*whispering* Okay
*rapid breathing*
Joy
Inside
My soul
Happy
Happy, joy, joy
Happy, happy, joy, joy
*scared beaver noise*
*shouting* Happy, happy! Joy, joy!
Oh my god!
*inhaling chipmunk noise*
If you could just, you know,
not do those things
that you're doing now, that'd be great.
Oh, fum
Oh fum!
Oh fum me!
*majestic mouse noise*
Okay, the flip was a nice touch
I suppose.
Okay!
We've just gotta ignore the bird pewp
And we'll be okay!
Oh ho!
Oh ho ho!
*french accent* Oh ho!
Oh
Oh ho
Oh ho ho, ho
Get under the wipers!
OH!
Under!
Interesting strategy!
Oh thank you! *inhales*
I am stuck!
Oh joy! There we go! *inhales*
Oh, you're so cute!
Ah-
Oh, bird pewp!
Bird pewp!
*dying prairie dog noise*
Eh-
*chinchilla noise*
*unintelligible screaming*
O-OH. Can you-
*higher, insane voice* I don't know what you're doing!
I don't know anymore!
*calm voice* I can do this.
if I just believe in myself!
If I believe in the heart of the bread!
*porcupine noise*
Okay!
Ha
Okay, you didn't grab on there. Can you see where you went wrong?
Okay, you're just humping bricks now. That's
That's not- that's not- that's not what I
Okay *lemming noise*
If I let go, are you gonna fall over?
*screaming* You are!
You are!
Oh my- OH MY GOD!
*Mark noise*
NO!
*inhales*
*exhales*
*sighs in relief*
*another sigh*
I didn't think you were
And you betrayed me.
That's the thanks I- OoOh
Oh- WhoOo
*surprised laugh*
I went the long way around, didn't I?
I could've gone that way!
And I would've been just fine!
Wouldn't I have, huh?
*tiny Mark noise*
*shrieks*
Hoookay
That is
Not ideal.
How do I go-
Oooh- heh- ha
Owwwwwhooaaa
Okay, we got it
Okay
Just, uh, slap something
Slap something
Slap- Okay, that's an option
*terrified Mark noise*
Eh- Ohho! Ohho!
Ohho, ohho
Oh, oh, oh, oh-
*screams; sighs*
Fuck
Ee
Oh, ah
Hee, ho, ha
Okay, just *yells*
*yelling* What are you doing!
You're so energetic!
And I don't like it!
Slap?
Why did I bother going the long way around
I have no id-
Ohhh, I have no, eiii have no
No idea
I- OoOkay!
Camera!
I don't like you very much and you
don't like me but
Oooh my god
Oh my god
Oh-OooOoOh
Oh my god, oh my god, go!
*screams*
Ow!
What is that?!
What is that?
Do I need that?
I don't know what that is but okay!
OoOh! Okay!
*in higher voice* Get stuck, I guess!
Okay
Hooh
I don't know what we did
Hoh- nyeh
Oh, OH
Just rest
Rest
Take a break
I don't know what we did
But we did something
*turtle noise*
*shrieks*
No! You were up there!
You were-you were-you were up there
You were up there!
What broke!
What's sparking!
Oh my god; you are kidding me
Do I go under it or do I go
Over-under. Do I touch it?
I-I don't know
I don't know what I need to do
There's glass there
I don't think anyone even notices what I think is weird anymore but
You know what, it's fine. *inhales*
*continuous yells*
*voice cracking* Oh come on, be nice to meeEe
Think I can make it over it I sprint across the ground here?
No, no, just
Go, go faster
Oh, oh, oh, not that way.
Oh my god
Oh my- Oh my god
Oh my god, no!
No! Not like this!
Not like this- NO! I'm right there!
*screaming* NO!
*crying* Oh noooo
*desperate weasel noise*
*sobs*
You- I- fu-
*screams*
Oh! Why! Why would you do that to me!
Why would you do that to me!
Why would you do that to me.
*muttering* Why would you do that to me. Oh.
Yeah, oh, oh
Oh, Slay
Can you just grab on!
What?! Why!
I don't understand your logic!
*screams*
*in high voice* I'm a flag!
Flailing in the wind!
Oh god
Oh go-
Oh my god
*screaming* Oh my GOD!
Just- oh fuck. You're gonna run out of Grip, aren't ya
Run out of grip right while-
Why are you slapping!
*screaming* Why is the camera so bad!
*shrieking* Oh no! Just go! Just go!
*exhales*
*inhales rapidly and starts to hyperventilate*
*exhales torment from the inside*
*angry noise*
Lighters? I like the sound of that!
Ooh! Ooh!
Flickity, flickity, floo, flah!
Ooh!
Sparky!
Okay?
So what about that?
Oooooooohhhhhh
I get it
Uh- ohhhhhhhh
I get it!
It's not that the sparks
WhyyYYy
OOokaAy
Hooly shit
Oh my gahh-
Oh my- oh my- *laughs semi-maniacally*
Calm the fuck down!
Okay, alright. *yells*
*relieved kangaroo noise*
*inhales between teeth*
*shouts inner torment*
Nailed it?
So, it's not that,
The sparks are-
What's gonna give it to me
It is
The gas
That I spill
And that
*screams*
WHY
Why did you do that!
Why- explain yourself!
To me! Please!
WHY
Why did you do that?
Why did you just do that?
How did you just do that?
What in the fuuhck
Okay, there we go, there we go
Ah
Not where I wa- okay
I'll take it?
There we go!
Okay, now that that's sparking,
If I pour gas there,
It'll light on fire.
Riiiight?
Riiiiight.
And fire is what I waaaant
Riiiight?
*slowly going insane* Riiiight.
To burn every copy of this game in existence
That's what I waaaant
Oh, freaking go-
I, why, are
*inhales rapidly* Ohh!
No, no, no, not now
Not now
*shrieking* NOOOO!
NO!
OH MY GOD, NO!
No, no, don't panic
Don't panic, oh my god
Why are you not going?!
Oh my god
OH MY GOD, ARE YOU KIDDING ME
NO!
OH MY GOD
WHAT THE FUCK! Ah!
Ah!
OOOOOH NOOOO!
*crying* I don't get you,
Why don't you get meee
There we go-
Oh yeah
Chaos reigns
Chaos
Reigns
And that means that I
Can roast myself if I can just
Get that power up
*exhales*
Oh, oh, oh, what are y-
Ge- what are you doing
Get-
Oh my- oh my god, no!
Oh my fucking god!
Oh my
GOD
*calm voice* I'm okay
As long as I think happy thoughts, I'll be just fine
because I am almost there.
With barely any edibility left
Aw- no
No, no, not like this!
No!
YOUUUU PIECE OF SHIT!
I WAS JUST CALM!
*murmuring* I'm fine
Here we- okay
So raging fire, yes?
Raging fire, yes
Oka- oh
What?
Oh- oh- ohh- ohhh
*ding*
*Mark noise*
*another Mark noise*
Hey!
*laughs desperately*
I got a B!
*laughs out the remaining insanity*
Ooohhh
Kay
Okay
*whispering* I did it
And I don't know what that Epilogue is but I
I'll look at it?
I'm gonna look at it?
And then if it's something-
What?
"To whom it may concern, it was the bread.
It's always been the bread.
It needed to become toast
And it would not stop at nothing.
My house was the start but it won't be the end.
I was forced to escape the Therapy Barn
I should've destroyed the bread while I had the chance.
Now there's been an explosion across town and I know it's the bread.
I'm gonna find this cursed loaf and end this once and for all."
Uh
I- I don't wanna- I
I don't- I don't- oh
*slap*
I don't wanna do this.
No
Uh uh!
No way
Nu uh, nope
Not happening. Nope
Not gonna do that. Not now, not-
Not- not now. Not- not now
That is all for I Am Bread for now.
I cannot handle, emotionally,
I've done three in a row.
And that was pushing my sanity. (Weren't you already insane Mark?)
But I feel good now, because I did it.
I did it, everybody, I did it!
Hooray for me!
I did it
So thank you, everybody, so much for watching
Thank you everybody who believed in me
All this time
And I will get to the Epilogue
As soon as I am mentally recovered from this exhausting evening
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
And, as always,
I will see you
In the next video!
Buh bye!
*Mark's outro music* (If you want to dance just do it. I we won't judge.)